[Música]
según el nuevo informe del panel
intergubernamental de expertos sobre el
cambio climático publicado el 4 abril
denunció la falta de voluntad política
para mitigar el aumento de la
temperatura a nivel global el documento
afirma que no será fácil moderar la
devastación de nuestro planeta pero
tampoco es imposible sin embargo
asegurar que el momento para hacerlo es
ahora o nunca este grupo me elabora un
resumen detallado de la climatología
cada seis u ocho años y divide sus
hallazgos en tres informes aseguran que
tendremos muchos problemas si no
actuamos con rapidez y la rapidez es la
que nos falta en este momento por eso
quiero saludar entonces a nuestro
segundo invitado del día eres álvaro
shop para ti licenciado y magíster en
relaciones internacionales especialista
en políticas climáticas globales
expertos a la oficina regional para
américa latina y el caribe del programa
de naciones unidas para el medio
ambiente gracias a álvaro por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
es y qué hace el el ipcc
muy buen día era un buen día toda la
audiencia bueno el ipc se como bien has
mencionado antes es un organismo que
compila valida integra todos los
hallazgos científicos relacionados con
el cambio climático a nivel global y
también intenta dar mensajes compactos y
claros para la toma decisión política de
la manera más fundamentada
científicamente así que ese es el gran
trabajo que desarrolla el ipcc ahora
álvaro vamos a enfocarnos en este último
y tercer informe que presenta este
organismo hablemos del contexto además
de los informes previos que presentaron
anteriormente y cómo se puede leer este
último
como también un bien ha indicado el ipc
se desarrolla distintos informes el
primero que ha salido recientemente fue
en septiembre que es el que aborda las
bases físicas y los cambios observados
en el clima en las concentraciones de
gases el segundo informe que también fue
publicado recientemente en febrero habla
de los impactos que se han observado y
los que se proyectan así como también
las respuestas es decir las conocidas
como medidas de adaptación que se vienen
desarrollando o las que se deberían
desarrollar a futuro para dar cuenta de
este fenómeno y poder hacerle frente y
este tercero informe aborda lo que se
denominan las causas es decir la
cuestión de las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero y las posibles
respuestas ante estas crecientes
emisiones esto se denomina en el mundo
del cambio climático como mitigación es
decir reducción de emisiones o aumento
de absorción estos gases mitigación que
no estamos cumpliendo de ninguna manera
pero también le quiero preguntar
entonces las posibles consecuencias de
este aumento de temperatura que ya es
inminente y que ya no vamos a alcanzar
esa meta de 1.5 grados sino que así
hagamos lo que hagamos el día hoy va a
ser más
bueno gracias por esa interesante
pregunta según lo que dijo el informe
recientemente todavía hay una pequeña
posibilidad de alcanzar esa meta pero
eso recibían los esfuerzos es realmente
muy muy grandes y muy rápidos a nivel
global y simultáneos en lo que hace a la
reducción de emisiones en todos los
sectores que componen la economía pero
volviendo la primera parte de la
pregunta efectivamente si esto no se
logra o si el aumento es mayor a 2
grados
inclusive los cambios observados y los
cambios a futuro van a ser realmente muy
probablemente irreversibles entre ellos
mucho de los impactos que recientemente
mencionó el doctor franco que me
precedió y también impactos en la
infraestructura en los sistemas
productivos no sólo por los cambios
repentinos bruscos sino también por
cambios graduales que ya se vienen
observando como cambios en los patrones
de precipitación aumentos graduales en
las temperaturas todo eso va a afectar
severamente al sistema económico
productivo y social de todo el mundo
pero es que al ver a cómo reducir todo
esto si pongamos el ejemplo de la guerra
en ucrania que estamos viendo en este en
vez de los países de acelerar este
cambio de energía y esta transición a
una energía limpia una energía no fósil
viendo todo lo que ocurre en rusia y con
las sanciones del gas ruso el carbón
etcétera estamos volcados entonces
viendo no sé por ejemplo arabia saudita
u otros países para seguir consumiendo
energía fósiles porque en usar este
detonante digamos de la guerra para
cambiar ahora mismo que es realmente lo
que necesitamos además saliendo de una
con 26 el año pasado que parece que nos
sirvió para nada
y es muy interesante la pregunta primero
esta cuestión de la guerra puso
bien a la vista toda esta cuestión de
más a la vista la cuestión de los
combustibles fósiles y sobre todo la
relación de europa con ellos
efectivamente a nivel mundial los
combustibles fósiles proveen la mayor
fuente de energía que consumimos sobre
todo para la generación de electricidad
o de calefacción o también para lo que
hace el transporte el mundo depende en
gran parte de por ahora de los
combustibles fósiles aunque no
únicamente sin embargo se están dando
cambios bastante interesantes en muchas
matrices energéticas de muchos países
que están tratando tendiendo a
descarbonizar las es decir depender
menos de estos de estos combustibles de
todos modos esto es algo sumamente
necesario aunque es difícil de hacer en
términos con corto tiempo por las
cambios tecnológicos que se necesitan
por las altas inversiones
todas estas cuestiones hacen que los
cambios no sean tan tan fáciles de
llevar a la práctica aunque son posibles
y realmente necesarios en estos tiempos
claro es difícil por ejemplo en una
región como américa latina y el caribe a
diferencia después de europa y países y
regiones desarrolladas con esta crisis
de alimentos con esta crisis de
combustibles pues obviamente primero
primar la comida para la gente que puede
reducir eso entonces ahí estamos en esa
disyuntiva gracias a esta guerra pero
hablemos entonces de las soluciones
vamos a ponernos un poco más optimistas
antes todo este panorama que pintó un
poco catastrófico soluciones
tecnológicas financieras políticas
sociales individuales que podemos hacer
nosotros
y nuevamente gracias a las soluciones
son muchas las posibilidades de solución
son muchas dependiendo el sector por
ejemplo como has mencionado américa
latina y el caribe no tienen una matriz
energética tan tan carbonizada como
otras regiones esto es debido a entre
otras cosas la gran generación de
hidroelectricidad decir ingeniería en el
energía hidroeléctrica producida por
grandes centrales también hay un
creciente uso de la energía eólica y
otras fuentes o también de la biomasa
pero en cuanto a las soluciones
dependiendo los sectores tenemos dos
opciones voy a dar algunos ejemplos en
lo que hace el sector del transporte que
es uno de los más críticos la cuestión
de la electrificación del transporte es
una primera medida aunque luego hay que
pensar siempre de dónde va a venir esa
electricidad entonces si esa
electricidad sigue proviniendo de
fuentes fósiles la solución no está tan
al alcance por ello hay que considerar
todas soluciones integrales como por
ejemplo generación de base que no tenga
alta intensidad e carbono y no tenga
carbono directamente y luego la
electrificación de los medios de
transporte eso es un ejemplo otro
también siguiendo con el transporte y
algo relacionado con las ciudades que
son uno de los principales
espacios o entornos donde se producen
las emisiones tiene que ver con esto que
ya se mencionó antes del transporte no
motorizado es decir que estos cambios en
los hábitos de
transporte de los ciudadanos es muy
importante en la medida que sea posible
esto es sólo un ejemplo para un sector
que es la energía y el transporte pero
podemos dar otros ejemplos para otros
sectores